how far back can we look now with the
web telescope and that's newest large
scale deep peering telescope that was
launched into space and how far back
have we pushed the Horizon of view now
so yes the James Webb Telescope was
launched on Christmas Day and 2021 and
it's been sending back phenomenal images
what makes the web telescope so powerful
is not that it can see farther back in
time although it can in a certain sense
but it doesn't have extra magnification
and that's not required to see things
that are farther away in other words if
you use a tiny little telescope like the
sort that Galileo used back in 1609 to
spot the craters on the moon's surface
you could use Hubble Telescope can also
look at the Moon and it won't see things
that are you'll see more detail on the
moon's surface but it won't see farther
than the moon because the Moon is in the
way now if you look where there's no
moon where there's no planet where
there's no galaxies where there's no
absorbing matter whatsoever then you're
seeing back to the creation of whatever
light your telescope is sensitive to now
visible light has only been around for a
few billion years because before that
time because of the universe's expansion
that light has red shifted and has gone
from visible light to infrared light
which is invisible to our eyes but
highly visible and that is the Quarry
that the web telescope is seeking now if
you go farther than the infrared then
you come to microwaves which is what I
study so the longer the wavelength the
light you're looking at the farther you
can go back in time not because you're
impeded by something but because the
source the very source that you're
looking at has been a diminished in
intensity and has been readden by the
expansion of the universe which is a
phenomenal discovery that we've only
known about for less than 100 years but
because of that Universal expansion we
can only see using particular
wavelengths of light and so that's why
the earliest light in the universe
there's no light that we could ever see
that is more primitive than the cosmic
microwave background that I and my
colleagues are studying the web
telescope can't see far back in time as
we can but that's really irrelevant it's
designed trying to do something very
specific look at the first galaxies that
form the first stars that form
exoplanets in other Stellar solar
systems in our own Galaxy and because of
that phenomenal machine and unrivaled in
its capability
foreign
[Music]